- [Woman On Phone] Hello?
- Hey.
- [Woman On Phone] How are you?
- I'm really well.
How are you?
- [Woman On Phone] I'm
trying not to freak out.
- [Gary] (laughs)
That's a good strategy.
We don't want to spend our
entire 60 Second Club
on the freak out.
- No, no, not at all.
- [Gary] Very cool so what do
you want to do in our time here?
- I actually wanted to know,
I know that in a couple of your
Snaps you said you have a family
and I know you don't show your
kids on Snap and
stuff like that.
But I'm just curious on
how you balance it all.
I kind of do a couple different
things and for a while there
I kind of felt like I had
everything at
least up in the air.
And then it kind of all came
down and now just trying to get
everything spinning again.
I just feel like I was doing
good on one then I'm failing at
another and I just want to
know how you balance it all.
- [Gary] I think
I balance it all by
not judging myself too harshly.
I think that's really
where it starts and stops.
I think way too many people
have lost the work-life balance
before it's even started because
they're gonna be critical on
themselves regardless of it.
Right, it's so hard to balance
and so for me I just know
I'm doing the best that I can
and if I'm doing the best that
I can that in itself has put
me in a position to succeed.
And some days that means that
I have to choose my family time
on a Friday night or
Sunday morning,
an executive ran into me on
Saturday and asked me to meet
for coffee and wanted to
jam and I just couldn't.
I couldn't because
of the family time, right?
And so that's the
family being chosen.
Other times I'm flying and
speaking somewhere or having a
big meeting and I'm missing you
know some sort of like school
function that I didn't want to
miss and that's the other way
and the truth is I just
don't beat myself up.
All of us are trying the best we
can and so as long as nothing is
glaring and to me glaring is the
following: my kids have become
completely horrible people and
have major problems in society
and/or I go directly out of
business in my businesses.
As long as neither one of those
are happening I think
it's gonna be okay.
And so I think it's how you
judge how you're balancing way
more than the reality of it
and recognizing that you have a
different point of view
on it then your partner,
then the kids, then your
business associates and I think
you need to care about your
point of view on it first and
foremost while being empathetic
to everybody
else's points of view.
- [Woman On Phone] Awesome.
(laughs)
That's a really good answer.
I know that, yeah, it's hard to
try and not judge what you're
doing and stuff like that.
- That's the game, right?
That's, like, everybody could be
failing at work-life balance if
they've decided that they're
failing at work-life balance.
- [Woman On Phone] Okay.
- So, as long as
you know you're not,
as long as your spouse or your
partner isn't saying I want to
break up or get a divorce and as
long as your kids aren't eating
pine tar and as long as your
banks aren't coming to foreclose
your business,
you're gonna be okay.
You know and I think people are
freaking out like I didn't even
see my dad until I was 15 and
I love him and we have
the best relationship.
There're people who've had their
fathers walk out of their family
and they didn't see them for
15 years and now they've great
relationships
because they've reconciled.
People are way too
judgmental and overanalyzing
work-life balance in today's
modern PR society.
- [Woman On Phone] Mhmmm.
- And so, if you feel good about
it then you'll win and I think
not judging yourself too harshly
because it is hard to balance
everything 'cause
that's life and
I just, I don't aim for perfect.
I'm not interested in
perfect, it's not real.
Perfect is fake
and so I just live.
- [Woman On
Phone] That's awesome.
Thank you. (laughs)
- You're welcome.
It feels better, right?
It feels better to
look at it that way.
- [Woman On Phone] Yeah,
I said it's hard and with little
kids and stuff, you know it's
like Mommy's not here,
Daddy's not here and
that's kind of all they see.
You know as much as they're
involved it's just kind
of hard some days.
- They're tougher
tougher than you think.
How old are they?
- [Woman On Phone]
Three and eight.
- Three and eight,
tell me anything you
remember being three. Go.
- [Woman On Phone] Not much.
(laughs)
- Interesting.
- [Woman On Phone]
Just being in a hospital.
- Right.
And you know what?
As long as you're counter
balancing it with love and one
of the biggest things, all these
parents judging people meanwhile
they're around 'cause they
work 9 to 5 but if they're not
deploying love and are in it
from 5 to 9 every night and on
the weekend what are
they really accomplishing?
Just 'cause you're there
doesn't mean you're there.
- [Woman On Phone] Right.
When you do have your
family, like you said,
when you have your family
time you just kind of say that's
family time and that's
kind of non-negotiable.
That might be
different times but...
- Yes and sometimes, most the
time it works out but sometimes
it doesn't, right?
Sometimes I can get distracted
and I'm just not willing to beat
myself up if I decided to go
down a rabbit hole for an hour
on a Sunday when I should've
been all in on the family.
That's just gonna happen.
I just--
- [Woman On Phone] Right.
- This is about not beating
yourself up and knowing where
your intent and your efforts are
and also knowing
life's a long game.
So in two, three years when I'm
taking my kids on business trips
and traveling with them and
showing them the world like
that's where the benefits
have come from
some of the sacrifices.
I don't know, I think
everybody, you know,
if they had the option of would
you rather have had your parents
around every minute from 1 to 5
but not be able to do all these
amazing experiences with
them from 11 to 18 versus the
alternative, I just have a funny
feeling all this will raise our
hand and say I'll take that
11 to 18 shit and I plan on
dominating that and some of
the sacrifices I have to create
between 1 to 8 is something
I'm willing to do and that's my
strategy and I don't give a fuck
if some parenting blogger says
that I'm not spending
enough time with them.
Fuck you.
- [Woman On Phone]
(laughs) Thank you.
- Let me judge you from afar.
Do you know what I mean?
- [Woman On Phone] Yeah.
Yeah, there's too many
people out there doing that.
I love your attitude and
I love your message and
I started following you
a couple months ago,
I love, I wait for
your content every day.
In fact, there's some
days that I know like,
I know that
sometimes if someone's like,
"I don't have time," and
this and that you're like,
"I'm gonna go audit
their social media."
And I'm like maybe I can piss
him off (Gary laughs)
my social media.
(laughs)
- I love it.
- [Woman On Phone] The good and
bad I'm doing at this point but
I really appreciate
you taking the time.
In fact, I was running from my
daughter's dance lesson with her
yesterday as I'm commenting on
your post and hash tagging and
I got home and I was like,
"I get to talk to GaryVee!"
And my husband's like,
"I don't know what that means."
- (laughs) He's like,
"What's that all about?"
Listen, honestly, and thank you.
Right now, I'm feeling really
good in my stomach because
I knew why I wanted to
do this 60 Seconds,
you know, I figured out my
health by tricking myself into a
system where I was accountable
to somebody else, I knew that
I wanted to do something more
for my community even though
that I feel like I'm at
the top of my game,
I wanted to be better than my
best self and I needed to trick
myself into a game
that made me bring more.
And at this moment,
right now, I'm super,
I've never been happier
about this 60 Second.
You know, the 60 Second Club is
fun 'cause it's fun to see how
many comments and you get in
this and it's crazy and that's
all fun but this
chat made it better.
- [Woman On Phone]
Well, thank you very much.
I appreciate you taking time.
- Take care.
Bye-bye.
- [Woman On Phone] Bye.
- That was fun.
- [Tyler] That was good.
You want to go?
- 60 Second Club.
Got to trick yourself.
(hip hop music)